Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and for the next three days I'm
hiking and camping in the tundra of
Alaska I'm catching fish hunting birds
staring down wolves and exploring places
few people have ever seen
[Music]
well I've been driving all day and I'm
getting a little hungry I think I need
to catch some dinner
it's a little green caddisplay just
landed on my glasses I think that tells
me what I'm going to be using as a fly
so that right there is an Arctic
grayling little skinny one a little bit
runny to eat I think we'll put them back
there you go
pretty fish
all right
extended there
oh there we go there we go
I haven't seen any real big ones yet but
there's a bunch of them in here
oh there we go
there's another one as soon as the sun
comes out you can just see Caddis is
flying all over the place
there we go
that's a nicer one
proper Grayling right there
it's a little Artic Grayling it's
probably the biggest
I'll take this one for my dinner
probably landed half a dozen Grayling
and lost a half a dozen more in about 30
minutes there's just tons in this pool
and the water's so clear a bit if I put
the GoPro underwater we can see them
[Music]
foreign
I think we need to pull over and make
camp
how's this for a camping spot
it's not too shabby it's already pretty
cold so I think I'm gonna get a fire
going and get some dinner made
gotta let that fire mature a little bit
before I can start cooking and look
around see if we got any berry bushes oh
here we go
crowberry
oh
oh I love crowberries
[Music]
look at that mushroom I'm pretty sure
that's an edible mushroom I'm like 60
sure I am not at 100 sure
some blueberries
not a bad little spot about 10 minutes
of picking and see I got a fair amount
of berries there
got some boiling bag rice I gotta think
of Indian coconut curry we're gonna sit
by the fire let that warm up
it's only about 40 degrees right now and
you can see right up there there's snow
on those mountains oh fall is here
I can hear a pack of wolves starting to
howl way out in the distance
that's way cool
[Music]
there we go chickpea coconut curry and a
fried Grayling oh it's all warm it
smells so good it's pretty cold out here
so I'd like to make some tea I'm just
gonna go ahead and boil up a bunch of
blueberries
you waste so much meat trying to fillet
a fish these little guys you just cook
them whole pull the backbone out and all
the ribs and why Bones come with it
don't lose any meat
all right
oh
I have so many berries in my herbal tea
it's kind of like a watery hot jab it's
good
well it's getting dark and it's very
cold outside it might get down to
freezing tonight so I gotta get my
shelter ready and get my bed made
foreign
I drove about seven hours today and
we're just about to our destination but
I've got to get up early in the morning
and I am exhausted so I'm gonna turn off
the camera I'll see you guys in the
morning
oh
there's a lot of things I want to do
today
if you breakfast
I'm gonna fill up my water bottle while
you got a chance
all right well I'm gonna go for a little
bit of a hike
check this out
these are rose hips they're really
common up here in Alaska and they're
really good
these ones are perfectly ripe
oh look there's a bunch of them right
here
Rose Zips have kind of a mushy texture
and they're not that sweet
but there's a lot of meat on them a lot
of vitamins in them if you mix them with
something else sweet like a blueberry
they're really good another nice thing
about rose hips is the berries don't
fall off in the fall even if there's
snow on the ground you can find rosehip
bushes with rose hips still on them
I brought my 22 rifle with me I'm really
hoping to get a chance to shoot a tarm
again tarmigan are kind of like a wild
chicken they're absolutely delicious and
they change colors they're brown in the
summer and white in the winter so
they're really well camouflaged but
they're kind of noisy so I'm keeping an
ear out for tarmigan calls
there's also a ton of wild berries and
edible plants out here in the tundra I'm
going to point some of them out to you
so like this right here
this is Labrador tea
and you can use it to make an herbal tea
this right here is Fireweed and it's
already gone to seed in the late summer
they get these beautiful pink and purple
flowers that are edible and in the
springtime you can eat the Fireweed
shoots
I believe these are leaned in berries
though they could also be wild low Bush
cranberries they pretty much taste the
same and look the same crowberry bushes
down here
crowberries are really underrated they
play second fiddle to blueberries and
you almost always find them where
blueberries are so people Overlook them
they can also be really hit and miss
with their flavor I think a good
crowberry it tastes better than a good
blueberry but a bad craberry tastes a
lot worse than a bad blueberry
so all this vegetation we got here is
what we call Tundra it's this Mossy
spongy vegetation mixed in with Willows
and a few trees large portions of
Alaska's interior look just like this
Ptarmigan like to swallow rocks and
store them in their crop in their neck
to help them digest their food but when
winter comes snow and ice covers up all
the rock in the early morning in the
fall the tarmigan will come out to these
trails to pick up rocks for their crops
in preparation for winter time so
hopefully I'll find the tarmigan doing
just that
foreign
too I bet I can hear a bald eagle I can
hear some Little Tweety Birds I can hear
a tarmigan way down the hill
it's amazing how many more animals you
hear if you just don't make as much
noise
starting to hear my stomach rumbling
oh look here's a nice little Blueberry
Patch
berries are still good but they're a
little tart I think it's because we had
such a cold wet year
just heard a bunch of explosions
there's a bunch of fighter jets overhead
doing Maneuvers they keep breaking the
sound barrier and there's this big Sonic
Boom
oh fox has pooped right on this rock to
mark his territory foxes wolves and
coyotes will often walk a circuit
through their territory following almost
the exact same path every time so when
you see a spot like that where the fox
is marking his territory you put a trap
there when the fox comes back to Market
again
you get them
kind of keep losing the path in this
section
if you're ever in that scenario always
go up because it's a lot easier to spot
the path from High Ground than it is
from low ground it sure looks like
there's a path right there maybe
it's a good Berry Patch
oh there's so many blueberries
probably smashed a gallon of blueberries
just walking
oh
yeah
all right oh I'm gonna have the blue
twosies today
totally worth it you know it's always a
good idea
turn around and look backwards from time
to time burn into your mind what the
trail looks like when you're heading the
other direction
that's bear poop right there
as long as you have good visibility you
don't have to worry too much about bears
only when you surprise each other that
things get really nasty
do this right here
this is a plant called Arctic Lupine
it's one of the few poisonous plants
here in the tundra in the summertime it
gets this beautiful purple flower
foreign
bones
probably like a baby Caribou or
something
oh look at that man that is a gorgeous
River there's got to be Grayling in
there I figured I'd bring my gun or my
fly rod but not both
ah if I drop my pack and go quickly I
can probably go back to the car get my
fly rod and be back here in three hours
this big gravel patch is a nice easy
Landmark so I put my bag right there I
see it's right at the foot of that
mountain it's next to that Lone Pine
Tree
at the foot of that Ridge
there's some wolves
there are two wolves on that Hill
right there
those wolves were following the same
Trail I was
that seemed to scare off that wolf
because wolves were not afraid of me if
I had a real gun I could have shot those
three wolves I could have used those
pelts too I don't know how many wolves
are in that pack but I saw at least
three
oh I can smell them
like a dog kennel
hopefully I scared him away I don't want
them circling around me and getting my
pack
smell the Wolves again
wolves have a very interesting way of
hunting
they're very good at long distance
endurance so they'll just follow a herd
and trot behind it and push the herd and
push the herd until the weak and the
sick and the young can't keep up
and then they get them
oh I just realized I forgot my griddle
in the car I guess it's good I came back
for the fishing rod hey another fly ride
now we go back
well the Wolves didn't get my backpack
oh my God I'm tired probably eating a
liter of blueberries but I think I'd
like something a little more substantive
a little date on a stick there a little
bit of cheese here
uh-huh
the winds died down and it's warmed up
just a hair now the bugs have come out
and the mosquitoes are bad but the gnats
are so much worse they land on you crawl
up in your clothes and bite you give you
these little welts even with the
bug repellent they can get so nasty that
you have to wear a hood
but a little bit of wind or cold weather
will wipe them out so this time of year
they're only a problem in the middle of
the day if the sun comes out and the
wind dies down but the campfire smoke is
helping keeping them away
all right I think it's time to rig up my
fly rod and find out if three hours of
hiking was worth it
[Applause]
I had to put my coat on and pull up my
hood because the bugs are so bad but
hopefully the fishing's good man it
looks like this should be loaded with
grayling
there's got to be something in here I
just can't believe there is a grailing
in here
I'm not skunked but that's not what I
was intending you don't usually see the
little baby Grayling and the big ones
hanging out in the same places so that's
that's not a good sign
looks like the wolves have been busy I
think I'm gonna climb on top of this
Ridge here and allow me to get a better
view of the river
it's a lot easier walking up there as
well
all right
carmigan right there
I hope you guys appreciate how hard it
is to stalk and shoot a bird while
holding a gun one-handed in the camera
in the other
there we go
now right there's the willow Tom again
the Alaska state bird
you can see how it's brown and then
starting to turn white
I saw about six of them fly over there
oh hunting Target with the 22 ain't easy
but it sure is fun hard part is catching
them out in the open so you can get a
good shot at him I used to be pretty
good at shooting on the wing with the 22
but it's been a lot of years
I've been following the stream looking
for a deep spot I can see where it dumps
into the lake
oh that sure is pretty tell you what
you'll be hard-pressed to find a more
beautiful campsite I think this is where
I'm gonna camp for the night this ground
is nice and soft too
I'm gonna go down to the river get some
water see if I can't catch a fish
how do I get down here without breaking
my neck
oh there we go
that's not a big Grayling but that's an
actual edible one
going Downstream seemed to pay off
oh there we go that's an even better one
now it's a very skinny Grayling but
that's a proper size
fly fishing for Arctic grayling has got
to be one of my favorite types of
fishing just seems like Grayling are
always in the mood for a dry fly got
another one
little guy I'm gonna let him go oh got
another one oh that's a pretty one ah
you know what I'm gonna let him go
I think I landed about eight or ten
Grayling in a pretty quick period of
time but uh I think I need to get back
off that hill and get Camp made I got
food to cook up
all right I'm gonna let the little guy
go
I'll keep the big one
all right got a fish got some water I
think it's time to go make some dinner
now the tough part I gotta get back up
that hill
it's nice and warm out here but man the
bugs are getting intense
yeah it's time to set up the tent and
I'm liking this little spot it's flat
level soft and you got a little bit of
depression so the wind isn't hitting the
tent
[Music]
I'm gonna go ahead and filter the water
I took from the river and go ahead and
put my bottle in this Parky squirrel
hole
gravity pulls the water through the
filter and into your bottle
all right I think it's time to get
serious about picking blueberries
ah the the hazards the blueberry picking
but I got about two pounds of
blueberries here so that's not bad at
all
make sure to do this downwind from your
camp
otherwise you'll have feathers in
everything
this is what was inside the tarmigans
crop blueberry leaves make sure I throw
all the guts way down the hill I don't
want these anywhere near my camp
there we go there's the Grayling and
tarmigan all cleaned and dressed it's
not a ton of meat but it'll make a good
meal
all right I'm gonna pour about half the
blueberries into this bag
yes it does adds some water to the
blueberries
and all the sticks and leaves will float
and you kind of just skim them off
all right we go got some clean
blueberries
foreign
I'm making a little blueberry sauce to
go on the tarmigan and it's super easy
just throw in a bunch of clean
blueberries just put a dash of water in
the bottom of the pan boil everything
until it's the consistency you want
well I didn't know whether I was going
to get any tarmigan or not today so I
brought some lamb steaks just in case I
think I'm gonna eat those too I walked
12 miles a day I earned it
all right
well it's starting to rain I think I
better eat my dinner quickly all right
I'm gonna put some blueberry sauce on
our tarm again
that's good that's really good
that's not bad I didn't overdo it
that was good but this rain and wind is
getting me cold I think I need to get
inside
it was really cold last night I am going
to go ahead and put on some adhesive
body warmers
you know what I have them and I don't
like being cold might as well right
got my stretchy pants on I'm gonna put
my legs in the sleeping bag and I'm
gonna eat lab in bed
it's been a good day and a good meal I'm
gonna finish it off with a coconut
flavored chocolate covered macadamia nut
so good and for second dessert melon
flavored KitKat straight from Japan
absolute favorite KitKat flavor
um
well it's late and it's getting cold I
think I'm gonna boil a bottle of water
to put in the bottom of my sleeping bag
foreign
ERS of boiling water to put down in my
bag I'm doing well but it's late I'm
going to bed I'll see you guys in the
morning
oh man it rained
I raid a lot last night
well it seems we survived
got this just Add Water muffin mix and
we use it to make some fresh blueberry
muffins
I'm gonna add some blueberries
might not look like a lot but that's
like three muffins worth
we're gonna let those muffins cook in
the Steam for about 20 to 30 minutes and
if the water level starts to get too low
we're gonna add a little bit more water
to it
there we go steamed muffin you can tell
the steamed muffin's done because it'll
start to crack at the top but when you
give it a little slap it doesn't slosh
around and jiggle
oh
it's just like it's baked in an oven
only softer and it's got fresh
blueberries
oh that hits the spot well it seems like
I got a little break in the rain I think
I need to get this party cleaned up and
we need to hit the trail I got a long
way to get back home
so we're a little wet last night I
put them in the bottom of my sleeping
bag up next to that water bottle and
they're nice and dry now
well I'm all packed up but my fingers
are freezing it is so cold out here we
are this close from getting snow instead
of rain my fingers are frozen oh this
has been an awesome campsite but we've
got several miles to go to get back to
the car and there is no Trail here's the
car
here was the lake by the car okay and
here is the trail I followed and I
followed the trail until it disappeared
and then I kind of went cross country
and I stumbled upon
the river
okay then I followed the river along we
camped there is I'm gonna go this way
now there's no trail and I don't have a
map but I know that there's a big
mountain right here and there's a
mountain right here so if I just stay to
the top of the two mountains I should be
able to make it back to the car
got to be really careful picking my way
I don't want to walk through a brush and
get my pants soaking wet that's an
important part of backcountry survival
don't wet your pants so if I'm not
mistaken I think that should be the
first Hill I need to follow to get back
home if I'm wrong I'll be able to see
you the right hail from the top of that
one so either way I'm getting on top of
that mountain yeah I think I'm on the
right Hill
well I hope you enjoyed watching this
video as much as I enjoyed filming it if
you want to see more videos from the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click subscribe alright I'll
see you next video If you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]